on va écouter à grandmont jours à tous à
tous nos amis de paris moi je voulais
vous dire que je suis vraiment très très
heureuse que vous m'ayez donné
l'occasion de parler devant les
militants parce que cher philippe tu le
sais bien
il faut absolument mobiliser paris pour
cette élection régionale
et c'est toujours le souci c'est que les
parisiens ne vote pas pour les
départementales puisqu'ils votent qu'une
seule fois
c'est pour la mairie qui est aussi
département et donc il faut remobiliser
paris pour lui expliquer qu'il ya une
élection régionale et que paris a aussi
une région l'ile-de-france
alors je vous en parlais mais avant de
vous en parler je voudrais d'abord vous
dire à quel point le travail que fait
philippe goujon à la tête de la fédé de
paris me paraît un travail absolument
remarquable et exemplaire et je tenais
ici à ce que nous lui rendions tous
collectivement hommage
et je ne fais pas ça uniquement parce
que nous sommes dans le xvème et bien
voilà monsieur le député maire
non vraiment c'est très difficile de
d'organiser une fédé comme celle de
paris vous êtes la première fédération
militante des républicains est donc à ce
titre c'est évidemment très compliqué et
puis vous savez les républicains
aujourd'hui il ya pas mal de chapelle et
vous avez vu ce qu'on a réussi à faire à
baltard à baltard on a réussi à mettre
tout le monde sur la scène et même à
aller faire l'alliance avec le centre la
même alliance que celle que vous avez
faite aux municipales à paris et c'était
très important et et philippe il est le
garant le ciment de que tous ces
courants tout tout tout ces chapelles
tous ces grands leaders charismatiques
que nous avons aux républicains et bien
leurs partisans s'entendent dans une
fédération et c'est très important
alors je voudrais aussi féliciter
frédéric péchenard votre nouvelle
secrétaire départemental bon y'en a qui
ont ironisé qui ont dit un grand flic
pour la fédé de paris tout ça m'enfin
bon nous avons besoin d'autorité qui
pourrait le nier
nous avons besoin d'autorité dans la
société française et frédéric on le sait
tous ici c'est une main de fer mais dans
un gant de velours
donc c'est l'autorité sereine voilà on
pourrait dire la force tranquille mais
c'est pas le slogan la force tranquille
voilà je voudrais rendre hommage aussi à
tous à tous ses prédécesseurs et avoir
un petit mot tout à particulier pour
jean jacques giannesini parce que
jean-jacques c'est celui qui est le
coordinateur de la campagne régionale
sur paris et il fait un boulot
extraordinaire de mobilisation des
militants et d'organisation tous les
tractages donc merci changé
alors je salue évidemment aussi tous
tous les parlementaires qui sont ici qui
sont présents qui sont toujours là les
fidèles il ya pierre charon ya jean
françois lamour qui sont ici je suis sûr
toujours là toujours présente toujours
là toujours sur le terrain et puis je
voudrais dire quelque chose à nathalie
parce qu'elle est discrètement au
premier rang elle est discrètement au
premier rang mais je voudrais lui dire
que je vois le travail absolument
considérable et remarquable qu'elle fait
à la tête de l'opposition à paris et je
peux vous dire c'est pas facile d'être
dans l'opposition moi j'en ai mangé 12
ans d'opposition à la région donc
maintenant j'ai envie de renverser la
table vous comprenez pourquoi parce que
12 ans d'opposition c'est très difficile
mais je vais lui dire que c'était
exceptionnel parce que il faut imaginer
ce que c'est que la puissance du rouleau
compresseur du bulldozer hidalgo qui
avec elle
ben oui qui a avec elle en plus
j'allais dire une presse évidemment très
favorable structurellement très
favorable des milieux intellectuels
aussi structurellement très favorable
donc c'est toujours très difficile de
mener l'opposition à paris les parisiens
le savent qui l'amène depuis depuis des
années et des années un assemblement
mais je pense que nathalie elle a su
relever le défi avec beaucoup de panache
et avec gelée dire son charisme qui est
qui est énorme et que c'est très
important pour vous d'avoir un leader
charismatique à paris
alors comment est-ce qu'on peut gagner
l'ile-de-france
comment est-ce qu'on peut gagner
l'ile-de-france uniquement par notre
mobilisation uniquement par notre
mobilisation je vais en parler parce que
il y à ici tous les maires
d'arrondissement tous les maires
d'arrondissement de paris et c'est très
important pour moi que les maires
d'arrondissement soit là aujourd'hui je
vais en reparler
comment est-ce qu'on peut gagner il faut
que vous compreniez qu'il y a une
formidable démobilisation de la gauche
en ce moment une vraie démobilisation de
la gauche et bien il faut pas aller les
réveiller il faut pas aller les
réveiller en revanche il faut aller
réveiller tous nos électeurs
ils ont fait exprès de mettre cette
élection en décembre
ça fait depuis 1965 je crois que nous
n'avons pas voté en décembre
ils ont mis cette élection en décembre
en plein milieu de la coop 21 comme 21
on va sauver la planète
françois hollande va recevoir obama ce
sera au 20h tous à ce qu'ils veulent
c'est que personne ne sache et surtout
pas paris qui a une élection régionale
ce qu'ils veulent c'est que personne se
déplace peut-être que le 6 décembre 13
décembre il va neiger
peut-être que le cil et semble très
décent vous serez en train de faire vos
courses de noël
peut-être que le 6 et le 13 décembre
paris sera totalement cramer
d'embouteillage avec toutes les rues
fermées parce qu'il y aura des
délégations officielles donc le sujet
c'est que vous avez une dernière
occasion de dire stop à françois
hollande avant la présidentielle
c'est les 6 et 13 décembre et c'est ça
qu'il faut dire et
et j'ajoute que pour vous militant
parisien c'est absolument crucial que la
région bascule parce que c'est la région
qui vous aidera à reconquérir paris
c'est la région qui fera le contre
pouvoir à paris parce que ce qu'on peut
montrer à la région c'est à quel point
madame hidalgo ne fait pas le job
pourquoi je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
la région elle a deux ou trois
compétences clés la première c'est le
développement économique
nous avons six cent soixante mille
chômeurs en ile de france 660 mille
chômeurs le chômage augmente aujourd'hui
plus vite en ile-de-france qu'il
augmente dans les autres régions de
france
pourquoi parce que les familles partent
en province parce qu il fait meilleur
vivre les entreprises partent en
province parce que la fiscalité y est
plus douce
les jeunes partent à l'étranger ou en
province pour trouver pour trouver de
l'emploi et donc on a aujourd'hui il
forces vives qui quittent l'île de
france
80 % des franciliens 10 c les récents
sondages qu'ils préféreraient vivre
ailleurs ils préféreraient vivre
ailleurs est ce qu'on peut entendre ça
alors que paris est la plus belle ville
du monde
est ce qu'on peut entendre ça alors
qu'on a une région qui concentre
j'allais dire la fine fleur de la
recherche mondiale les plus grandes
écoles d'europe les plus beaux paysages
le plus beau patrimoine la plus belle
culture la meilleure gastronomie je dire
il ya un moment comprends pas comment se
fait-il que paris ne soit pas légal de
londres que paris soit moins attractif
que berlin pour les cultureux que munich
pour les chercheurs que barcelone pour
l'épée que barcelone pour les pme
le choc barcelone n'est pas très
attractif c'est sûr qu'il n'est pas très
attractif que barcelone pour les pme
l'autre jour je recevais je recevais des
gta l'as à la cci de paris et il y avait
il y avait des start-up les startups du
numérique qui disait qu'il préférait
s'installer à barcelone qu'à paris alors
on les a tous regardent dans la rade
immédiat d incubateur de start accord a
dit ouais mais avec toutes les charges
sociales fiscales etc
nous on a préféré aller se mettre à mort
seul bon voilà doc je reprends mon
souffle et mes esprits donc le sujet
aujourd'hui c'est que effectivement nous
avons un potentiel qui est totalement
inexploité sur l'ile-de-france et la
marque paris qui va avec la marque
ile-de-france paris région ile de france
c'est une marque on doit absolument
développer un vrai maire de paris comme
l'été jacques chirac en son temps il
emmènerait les pme parisienne avec lui à
l'étranger pour leur faire gagner des
marchés pour les développer pour créer
de l'emploi paris 1 un vrai maire de
paris qui voudrait faire du
développement économique
il s'intéresserait aussi à ce qui se
passe à ce qui se passe dans la banlieue
aujourd'hui madame hidalgo vous dit
paris est horriblement polluer mais la
faute à qui la faute à qui il ya un mot
extraordinaire qui ne franchit jamais
vous avez remarqué la frontière de la
bouche de la gauche ni les verts ni les
socialistes c'est un mot très simple
alors il nie la réalité comme ça
n'existe pas c'est le mot embouteillages
embouteillages de quoi souffre paris
sauf pas que de pollution elle souffre
de ses embouteillages et ses
embouteillages qui vous polluent et qui
est responsable des embouteillages
parisiens
et bien c'est le plan de déplacement de
madame hidalgo c'est les verts et les
socialistes et c'est eux qui sont
responsables de la pollution alors quand
j'ai madame cost qui arrivent et qui dit
ararat mon projet dépolluer l'air ça
fait 17 ans qu'elle est au pouvoir et
jean paul huchon ils ont rien fait ça
fait
mairie par ita gauche qu'est ce qu'ils
font alors ils ont un projet c'est on va
empêcher les voitures de circuler dans
paris
mais le problème les amis c'est qu'on
peut pas raisonner de manière égoïste en
matière de transports madame hidalgo
peut pas dire je veux pas de voiture
dans paris et en même temps pas financer
les transports en commun qui sortent de
paris quand elle dit je veux pas
financer alors qu'elles s'étaient de la
noë s'était engagée le prolongement du
rer e jusqu'à la défense je pas financer
la ligne ans qui vont en
seine-saint-denis bah qu'est ce que vous
voulez nous les pauvres banlieusards on
est bien obligé d'arriver à paris donc
si on a pas de transports en commun
si on a on les cramer cramique ramer
dans le rer or mais on prend sa voiture
voilà c'est tout et si madame hidalgo
voulait vraiment dépolluer paris et si
les verts voulaient vraiment dépolluer
paris il nous aiderait à construire des
parkings aux portes de paris pour qu'on
puisse laisser les voitures et qu'on
puisse ne pas rentrer dans paris en
voiture c'est ça ce qu'on veut c'est ça
ce qu'on souhaite
et il faut encore faudrait-il que ça se
fasse donc évidemment si je suis
présidente de région
moi j'irai au rapport de force parce que
la mairie de paris il a quand même
besoin des cofinancements région pour
faire un certain nombre de choses pour
faire des pauvres des centres de
formation pour faire du développement
économique des pme pour rénover les
lycées pour financer les universités
donc la maire de paris elle a besoin de
la région donc un moment donné c'est
important qu'ils aient un contre pouvoir
régional qui vous permettent de faire
avancer les choses
donc la pollution à paris c'est les
embouteillages résoudre le problème des
embouteillages c'est les parkings et les
transports en commun et bien il faut
qu'on le fasse
de la même façon moi si j'étais
présidente de région quand je serai
présidente de région
je veux développer une application
smartphone pour les parkings aujourd'hui
un quart des voitures qui circulent dans
paris aujourd'hui et qui créent les
bouchons 1/4 cherche une place de
stationnement
et oui il faut dire qu'ils ont tout
enlever
si nous avions une application sur le
gps de la voiture qui nous dit où est la
place la plus proche dans les parkings
souterrains ou en surface et qui inclut
aussi les parkings des particuliers
parce qu'aujourd'hui un particulier qui
part travailler le matin il peut avoir
envie de louer son parking dans la
journée ça c'est la logique un peu
j'allais dire contemporaine c'est
l'économie numérique qu'on pourrait
avoir du partage de parking privé si on
vous identifier le parking on vous sort
de la voiture et on vous d en bouteille
paris donc le sujet voyez c'est qu'il
faut mettre l'imagination au pouvoir
et c'est qu'il faut essayer de résoudre
vos problèmes et je veux être une
présidente de région des solutions et
les solutions elles toucheront les
parisiens alors je vous ai parlé de
pollution je vais vous parler aussi de
propreté
oui oui parce que j'ai vu qu'il y avait
des médias bien pensants qui avait
décidé que c'était pas bien de parler de
la propreté etc la région n'avait pas se
préoccuper de la propreté sauf que la
région c'est le développement économique
ou à mon sujet c'est que les
investisseurs et les touristes ils
viennent donner de l'emploi aux
franciliens mon objectif c'est qu'on
gagne de l'argent en ile-de-france comme
objectif c'est que les jeunes trouvent
un emploi et donc pour ça et bien il
faut que la région soit propre
moi je suis désolé les deux grandes
portes d'entrée à la région c'est roissy
la gare du nord
vous imaginez un investisseur qui part
de saint pancras à londres
gare magnifique quartier totalement
rénovée et qui arrivent gare du nord à
la chapelle voilà je crois que vous avez
tout compris
bon et bien les gars c'est la
responsabilité de la région donc le
sujet il est simple c'est un sujet de
propreté sa sujet d'attractivité moi je
ne me résous pas et j'ai vu philippe
goujon que des japonais dans le xvème
décembre dans le square georges brassens
pour nettoyer le square georges brassens
voilà qu'est ce que ça donne comme image
de la france
24e ville touristique la plus polluée la
plus sale paris voilà eh bien nous on
fera un fonds régional dead à la
propreté de l'île de france
est ce que je veux dire c'est que les
maires d'arrondissement pourront créer
les associations et nous nous nous
engageons à financer les associations
des maires d'arrondissement qui voudront
nettoyer paris
dernier sujet parce que je sais que vous
avez une longue matinée qui a plein
d'autres gens qui ont envie de vous
parler
la sécurité et oui la sécurité alors
c'est pas par hasard qu évidemment je
veux que frédéric rejoignent mon équipe
avec ici tout un aéropage de candidats
tous ce talentueux et déterminée la
sécurité nous avons un énorme problème
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on est en train de
créer des ghettos aux portes de paris
et moi je vous le dis je vais dire la
vérité dans cette campagne
la mixité sociale c'est dans les deux
sens on peut pas concentrés au même
endroit tous les problèmes sociaux on
est en train de faire des quartiers
ghettos dans paris alors quand je vois
quelques fois des idées des gens de la
gauche caviar
ils sont merveilleux ils disent ah ouais
il ya paris et puis à la banlieue à
banlieue pour eux c'est une terre
inexplorée c'est un truc c'est exister
au delà du périphérique wii et 10 voilà
donc qu'il y aille à paris qui est riche
et puissante et puis il ya la banlieue
qui est qui est pauvre et misérable
c'est la vision qu'a la gauche caviar de
paris et de la banlieue c'est faux c'est
complètement faux il y à damparis
aujourd'hui des ghettos il y à paris
aujourd'hui des zones de non droit il y
apparaît aujourd'hui des écoles dans
lequel l'ascenseur social ne fonctionne
plus parce qu'il ya plus de mixité
sociale et donc dans lesquelles les
professeurs ne veulent plus venir
enseigner dans le xvème aujourd'hui il
ya une classe qui classe les aides qui
l'aurait cru
donc moi je n'aurai pas peur de dire
dans cette campagne qu'il faut de la
mixité sociale partout et qu'il faut pas
concentrer les problèmes au même endroit
parce que si vous concentrer la misère
et les problèmes au même endroit eh bien
vous avez des poches de pauvreté qui
secret des poches d'insécurité qui
secret et la délinquance après elle se
transporte alors nous on va faire un
grand plan sécurité un grand plan
sécurité dans les transports le métro
parisien est celui dans lesquels les
femmes se sentent le plus en insécurité
voilà la réalité donc nous devons avoir
un plan sécurité dans les transports
je veux une police régionale des
transports qui couvre le métro les rer
et les bus parce que sinon des comprend
les bus il ya plus personne donc le rer
le métro et les bus je veux lutte contre
la fraude dans les transports une lutte
intransigeant parce que
parce que tous ceux qui ne payent pas
dans les transports ne sont pas des
délinquants mais je peux vous assurer
que tous les vandales tous les
pickpockets ils n'ont pas payé leur
ticket donc comment ça s'est passé à new
york pour la sécurisation du métro de
new york ont là commencer par lutter
contre la fraude
parce que quand vous lutter contre la
fraude vous sortez du métro toute une
partie de population qui vient pour
dégrader pour s'amuser et souvent pour
racketter donc le sujet qu'on commence
par la fraude
et j'ajoute en plus que la fraude ces
200 millions d'euros 200 millions
d'euros en moins de recettes pour la
ratp la sncf par an ces 200 millions
dont on a tellement besoin pour la
rénovation de la ligne 13 pierre
brigitte pour mettre fin à un certain
nombre d' aberration du système de
transport parisien
et puis on fera circuler un certain
nombre de métro la nuit pour permettre
aux jeunes parisiens et aux jeunes
franciliens de rentrer chez eux le soir
ça c'est très important le vendredi soir
et le samedi soir
et puis nous ferons un grand plan de
sécurisation des lycées et de leurs
abords c'est très important parce qu'on
a aussi de la violence maintenant qu'ils
arrivent dans nos établissements
scolaires sur la sécurité c'est pareil
je pense que la région peut aider à
financer des associations de sécurité
qui sont des associations de
sécurisation comme on dit de jeu pas
commandes de vie comment vos voisins
citoyens etc ou bien ou bien des
auxiliaires de vie de vie locale des
assistantes citoyenneté enfin bref toute
personne que les maires d'arrondissement
voudront mettre dans les rues pour
protéger et assurer le calme et la
sécurité de leur quartier la région
pourra venir vous aider dans le cadre
d'un grand plan sécurité dans paris
je m'arrête là je garde la suite pour
notre grand meeting celui vous allez
venir extrêmement nombreux le 5 novembre
à paris et je vous demande de vous
mobiliser
merci et je n'ai pas saluer je n'ai pas
saluer mon tête de liste mais vous le
connaissez il est il est sur le terrain
ce matin c'est pour ça qu'il n'est pas
encore arrivé et donc je vous demande
quand vous le verrez de lui faire là
aussi un accueil très chaleureux
puis arrive bournazel